the press conferences are over and the
countdown has begun it's time for e3 to
begin in earnest ladies and gentlemen
welcome to gamespot stage here on the
show floor I'm Chris waters one of the
hosts that will be guiding you through a
crazy array of demos all next three days
long and another one is joining me right
over here mr. Daniel Dwyer it's what
unfortunately everyone couldn't see was
Tim Schafer run over and do a dance of
water camera well who doesn't have a
game at e3 he still just shows up to
start messing around people what are you
doing here the magic of e3 ladies and
gentlemen it's crazy doors doors just
opened everyone's coming in Danny it's
day one yes like this let's not act like
we haven't been at this for like two
weeks already day one yeah just two days
of non-stop work press conferences
galore kicked it off with Bethesda ah
fall out big story from there mmm not
only did they show fallout they showed
fall ahead for like 30 minutes so much
fun and then they decided to rob my
sleep hours by releasing that app I
haven't playing that yep you got it
there it's this is by far the worst idea
ever to have like a a people management
simulator happening during your III it's
like the most stressful thing in the
world they're all dying at the moment
forward shelter gotta keep you gotta
call them back from the wasteland when
you're gonna not check in on them for
like five hours cuz you don't die
they're gonna run into a giant ant
they're gonna die I got pro tip I got no
electricity I got hardly any food and
water there's Babies everywhere but none
of them can work for me yet so it's not
producing anything now babies the hell I
think I'm the only person who didn't
choose for twenty as well I got volt 86
yeah solid number choice represent dude
so yesterday Microsoft EA Ubisoft sony
the gamut of press conferences yeah ah
sock Microsoft what was what was the jam
my stuff actually was pretty good in
light of what's happened afterwards it
kind of feels like you know that there
were Second Coming a second place and I
guess but they probably are but gets us
only later but Microsoft's first party
lineup was really good and one of the
things you have to remember is that Sony
showed off a lot of really interesting
games but if we're talking about 2014 in
games Microsoft has them totally beat
like there's loads of games coming in in
q3 q4 exclusives for the Xbox one
Sony's got nothing Microsoft of the
gears HD things coming out halo 5
Guardians Guardian yeah and they've
showed out they they actually leaned
into their v your stuff in a real way
like they showed hololens oh my goodness
hololens looked incredible subscribe
like that and they showed it on a table
that looks like any table it wasn't like
this setup studio kind of thing it was
like hey look you got you got a table
you could have a minecraft castle and
guess what they managed to figure out a
way of selling there I guess that's
augmented reality not blood but they
managed to like their future tech you
could see how it worked and that's
something they like oculus still
struggles with is like over the internet
like how do we show people what it's
like when you've got these friggin
things on your face when you've got them
because you're still consuming it
through a 2d screen which is
fundamentally not what VR is all about I
one of the highlights from that what for
me was recore yes new game they
announced it was totally did the thing
where it's like hey here's an adventure
and her trusty dog they're gonna go on
adventures oh there's gonna be peril
that's all gonna and halfway they killed
the dog yeah they killed the dog in the
trailer and then of course it's not
actually a dog it's like a little robot
core thing so that was a cool yeah i'm
looking for that gets KJ fune a sort of
making it like a good guy behind the
obviously megaman and why not mighty
number nine but also a load of really
good games on xbox systems dead rising
lost planet like big budget games so
it's really interesting to see another
franchise from him he's actually on this
stage in a bed I think three or four
hours time I'm talking to him so I can't
wait to grow up fantastic yeah we've got
a pretty stacked lineup one that's
coming up in just about 40 minutes that
I'm really excited for it was from the
sony press conference and horizon zero
dawn yes I the sort of tribal woman
hunting robot animals yeah but like it
treats them like animals yeah treating
them with compassion like there's this
sort of holistic sort of ecosystem kind
of thing going on that really subverts
the man versus machine that's like
machine is usually the other they like
intruder but no like this is just the
way the world is I think this is a much
more interesting fiction than what
gorillas have been working with
and in like Hill Zone had some
interesting ideas in it like the sort of
future and like nazism essentially yeah
I'm but I think what they're doing here
I'm really happy to see them break away
from the Killzone franchise honestly
shadow fall was almost not a kill zone
game it kind of feels like it's just a
different type of first-person shooter
and I think mechanically was really
interesting but to see them like
actually take a step back make a third
person game it kind of feels like a
mixture of like enslaved in terms of its
narrative and presentation and and then
I keep forgetting the name but wasn't
name of that game where you're shooting
around on Rockets on your ankles Oh fake
wish vanquish yeah like a wonderful game
the nominee people picked up there is
some yeah there's some quick maneuvering
and weapons switching which was sort of
a hallmark of the the vanquish sorta
action here dodging the giant I don't
know t-rex thing yeah so cool that's one
of the great things about III is getting
to see creators that you have these
associations with this this history with
trying something new yeah and getting to
flex creativity outside of the bounds of
really anything and come up with these
fascinating new ideas and for a long
time I think gorilla had this they could
kind of lean on their graphics in a way
that perhaps they didn't I guess they
probably spend a lot of time making her
games look as beautiful as they do and
this looks great too but I always felt
that the games were mechanically rather
uninteresting like some stuff in Killick
whose decent shooter but there was
really much going on with a game like
this it looks like they've they've
really sort of decided to dive into
gameplay complexity hopefully anyway so
in terms of the combat it looks a lot
more interesting than Killzone shadow
folders and I'm fascinated to ask them
is there going to be multiplayer because
Killzone multiplier stellar and have
them say well we're not talking about
that at this time uh of course horizon
was like the thing we did not expect
from the sony press conference there are
some other things that we may be in our
heart of hearts in avian are like
wildest forum fantasies dreamed about
happening Adam Boyes was chip just
before we went live was here but like
the biggest smile on his face cloud nine
man he's walking around Final Fantasy 7
remake not just HD skins like they're
doing the 343 industries halo
anniversary treatment bully like the new
cutscenes look gorgeous
and then of course they kicked off the
show with the Last Guardian yeah it's to
get one of them is interesting to get
especially the final fantasies of
squeeze considering what happened at the
Sony event back in December when they
had when they showed off their like oh
we're doing a final fantasy but it's
just a straight up like port basically
yeah for pc and eventually the ps4 don't
actually no comment up because for you
em but yet to show off the Last Guardian
to show it off to have the creative
leads there to show off a demo it was
very similar to what we saw those years
ago must be four or five years ago maybe
this stage and but then to actually have
it looked like it looks it looks really
good it looks like a next-gen game if
you go back and look at that other one
it has that sort of an eco shadow sort
of it doesn't have that crispness yeah
but i really i think mechanically the
gameplay demo we saw you said it made a
very good point in our post-show
yesterday that it was a pretty
rudimentary puzzle and I know I think
Peters gonna see it behind closed doors
today uh-huh so hopefully you can come
and tell us a bit more about it but yeah
it's great to see top just to see it
yeah but to see it end to be like okay
this thing still exists it's not
vaporware it's not a ghost in the wind
somewhere it's uh it's they've really
invested a lot it seems in feather
physics over the years I money in a
feather physics prize but certainly the
last guardian one of the big stories out
of III 2015 already and then the the end
of their trifecta of like checking off
long-desired games Shenmue 3 mildly with
the more the most secure of the bunch
and then they didn't announce the game
proper they announced hey we're making
this game but there's a Kickstarter yes
and we're asking for two million which
is like nowhere near enough to fund what
even what the game was back in nineteen
ninety one ever apparently adjusted for
inflation Shenmue 2 cost somewhere in
the realm of 60 million dollars yeah you
want to see what the total is as of
right now we're less than 24 hours away
or later and it's currently a 2.6
million two points salaries which is
pretty crazy is it weird to you for Sony
to come out and be like hey you guys
like games we're gonna show you games
yet now pay us to make this game so are
you either
must be something going on here like
we've seen with the the number of
kickstart is now at this stage that
getting some sort of public backing
getting that early investment leads to
them securing publishing which then
leads to them getting a bunch of money
for marketing and development and we
don't know what the relationship between
Sony and this project is it's clear that
there is some because they went on the
stage and did it whether or not like
this weird thing that none of the
stretch goals include a boxed copy of
this game on ps4 so it's it's kind of
vague there was a rumor last week that
Sony were going to do this that they
were going to announce a Kickstarter for
Shenmue 3 but that they were going to be
like sort of backing shadow backing it
if it did well so it's already crushed
it yeah cuz 31 days left on the bloody
thing and it's already beating its goals
it's probably going to be the most
successful Kickstarter of all time I
think it's probably the fastest for the
amount of money but what what that means
we don't really know yet yeah I mean we
even earlier this year with a
castlevania Kickstarter sorry well
spiritual successor to Castlevania
igarashi said ninety percent of this
game is funded I just need the show
faith yes from backers the interest and
so yeah it's a Kickstarter continues to
evolve as a really kind of interesting
way for games to come into being and get
funded and get attention and then this
morning of course Nintendo kicked it off
with their second event this week yeah
it's hard to tell because the tree has
stuff just seems to keep going so I
don't know like the event on was it
someday to have the the Nintendo World
Championships yeah I was pretty good
little wheeze represent Hillman he's got
a career in show casting line up from
all set and then yeah this morning was
the like Reggie wada shenanigans in the
video I think yeah they turned into some
starfox characters Star Fox zero is one
of the pillars standing over here in the
Nintendo booth just beyond the reach of
our cameras trust us also posted up
there we've got Yoshi's woolly world and
zelda triforce adventures that what it
says heroes heroes yeah i was at living
Tony in trouble I was interviewing Tony
Hawk while that was on so I've still yet
to see that stuff like you know Star Fox
interview Tonya I know I caught a bit of
the sperry I know right he was very
sitting right here he warmed this on
your latch for me it was a very intimate
moment and he's gonna be on the show as
well and then
just a couple of hours time talking
about pro skater 5 and but yeah from
what I heard upstairs Nintendo you knows
great see Star Fox it's always good to
see a bit of Zelda like they told us
they Telegraph that they're not gonna
have the new wii u Zelda game yep I
think that's a shame I think you know
with all the sort of massive games we
saw sub got those IGN Joker's walking
pastures with all those a big games we
saw from the other publishers
manufactures it was a little bit at
disappointing that they didn't have a
massive sort of showing but you know
well do you know what and that's
interesting to think about because
they're not showing the Zelda at e3 but
this III is no longer the only tentpole
place where publishers are going to come
and show off their big reveals their big
exclusives their first party stuff their
bombshell news look gamescom we've
ordered like microsoft had a murderer's
row of games of people looking forward
to that they weren't going to show and
that they're saying like scale bands not
gonna be here will show at them remedy
aren't even here yet so they're gonna be
showing off their crazy quantum break
game at Gamescom as well so yeah it's
like game coverage has changed so much
over the years but just like there was a
time when gamespot was the only but like
we've been doing it's like 18 years
getting spots with Nick around 83o yeah
so like it's changed so much and not
only has a change in terms of the way
you can get access to this stuff
obviously we're still the best but like
the amount of news we we get so there's
been this recurring sort of conversation
about III is it doesn't have that big
oscars kind of power behind it anymore
but you wouldn't know Matt [ __ ] me this
year I don't know and it's still pretty
big deal yeah I did it like this dude
we've got did an interview on NPR this
morning about me are verses AR cuz that
stuff it's always interesting to see
what stories from e3 you know it still
is sort of a lightning rod for
mainstream press attention what stories
sort of carry out to the broader market
and VR n AR is kind of one this year
although I was surprised that we didn't
see more via more movie our push I mean
you know Microsoft name-dropped oculus
and they're working with valve yeah but
I oculus press conference was last week
not a big showing here so far now in
Morpheus at Sony was was a barely
mentioned at all they said here's a
bunch is a sizzle reel of indie games
games you can play it here but you know
I think that
with VR not really coming to market till
next year I mean oculus is announced for
early next year and I think maybe
Morpheus has not even announced a time I
got imagine fall next year at the
earliest yeah so it seems like there
still may be figuring out the way to
market that's a consumers because like
we were saying earlier it's just it's
kind of hard to market and like you and
I can only do so much to describe the
experience exactly it's different for us
because we we get to play with these
toys all the time and I think everyone
was talking for the longest time about
2015 being the year for for virtual
reality I kind of feel like it's
actually probably 2016 once the oculus
is out like Microsoft don't really know
what they're doing they mentioned like
as you said they mentioned oculus they
also mentioned valve V or they also
mentioned hollow lens like when you're
on we do a lot of this stuff talking
like CBS affiliate radio stations and
when you're trying to communicate to
people the mass market which is what
they need they all need to do to sell
this of what their big push is like
we're it's still looking in five six
different directions there's no one way
of there's no lycra focal point for
virtually all I think this is the big
year for VR for a game developer yes yes
the game developers conference in san
francisco in march fee or everywhere you
lowly yet but then for consumers it
still got to be a ways off you know
gotta be next year hopefully you'll see
some more cuz u vr is pretty damn
awesome yeah i think the hololens stuff
actually i find very interesting because
this is almost like an application
software at this stage like a lot of
what microsoft have been showing off it
cited the video game space em husband
has been interesting so for them to
basically take their there's a little
diamond here at minecraft which is you
know you think of all the people who who
buy windows products they all have kids
now and the kids are all playing this
one video game and just look at this
like just no clipping your face you're
just looking in there like that's the
camera dipping in there with all ends on
top and I so do you think when you when
you saw this was that the moment that it
all made sense the two billion dollar
price tag for Minecraft Microsoft if
they can sell some augmented reality
headsets off but I'm sure that'll help
what it did was it outside of the
minecraft thing it's definitely a proof
of concept for them to be able to show
that yo you can basically create these
you know you can bring video games into
your
only the world like regardless of what
this does for the future of pornography
video games are going to be super
interesting absolutely popping up in
your living room it's it's a whole
different tech frontier in a way that
new consoles could never be a whole
different visual interface and I felt
like this is like cheating as well like
you can just straight-up look like no
clip through entire levels just like see
where everyone isn't John whatever
happened to just digging a hole in the
ground and finding out what was below
there exactly all right Danny well we're
queuing up to have about six hours of
demos here on the stage we're kicking
off with black ops 3 and then going on
to horizon until dawn those are two mice
two games i'm really excited to kick off
later on you are coming on stage yeah
who you got you've already talked about
Tony Hawk yes Tony Hawk got angry bird
from Microsoft's I'm gonna grill him
about what he thought about the Sony
conference I'm sure he'll be you'll love
to talk about that yeah I got Tony okay
jayna Funes coming on I've also got
winner that he's not he's he's on for
the new one he's not on for the old oh
I'm so mighty number nine if somebody
from phone comes on for that as well and
I think I start with guitar hero live
guitar hero live which i think i can say
now I we played at the office a couple
of weeks ago did you get a chance to get
with the new fret buttons it's really
cool that for people who don't know
guitar who never played them before and
for people who are like fans of the
series it's a whole new like its
remember like learning how to like type
on a keyboard for the first time yeah I
play guitar girl I you again hands on
the neck yeah it doesn't feel like oh I
play guitar over I can do this it's like
oh yeah and then there's all this CG
people shouting at you yeah hand cramps
yeah I like it it's it's a it's like the
same with tony hawk it's an excuse to go
back it's a real good time for some of
these franchises to come back I think so
I'm relooking boarded up it's gonna be a
wonderful lineup today here and this is
just our first day of three days
broadcasting from the gamespot stage
here on the e3 show floor Danny O'Dwyer
is going to be hosting I'm gonna be
hosting Lucy James from gamespot UK is
going to be hosting we hope you folks
stick with us the whole time it's gonna
be awesome
you